and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a are tonight's review x-men
Days of Future past oh my god this is
the greatest movie you've ever seen in
my life did it it is boilers did it it
is boilers dear see sky called Wolverine
and in the not-too-distant future of the
not-too-distant future every single
person has been taken over by machines
unlike today who that reminds me I had
to learn every bit of social media time
standing up right now but Wolverine is
like we have to stop this horrible
future that we've seen in every other
movie from happening oh come on what
other movie has a future taken over by
machines - it was written these man
what'd he do so they go to Juno cat to
send him back in time because she woke
up one morning and realized she could
just do that now I woke up one morning
and realize I could fart rainbows so
maybe that's because I smoked a laxative
with skills and so Wolverine is gonna be
sent back to the past but magneto is
like you must find me in the past as
well I'll be able to help you really cuz
given your track record in all the other
movies I find that very unlikely to
really I get the feeling just at the
prime of my angriest I'll be okay oh
hush up it's time to show the ladies my
butt okay
I mean it is butter set back in time to
find that Xavier used to be a drunk
walking mr. Thomas and Wolverine is like
what happened to you I got addicted to
legs you need to get off that addiction
and get your life together once you get
off the addiction of showing your naked
body in every movie never I got to get
my needle out of jail why because
apparently he was the second coming who
killed JFK oh come on guys I'm a bum on
the street even I find that hard to
believe then they tell us he was trying
to say J okay because he was a mutant
all along okay that's easier to swallow
Tommy break my needle out of the
Pentagon and go looking for mystique but
magneto decides he's too dangerous to be
kept alive and so he tried to kill her a
mistake it's like why are you trying to
kill me haven't you guys ever learned it
on the bad guy I will always be the bad
guy well I guess the real question is
why aren't you following you in sequels
because our continuity is as
straightforward as a porcupines back oh
that's why I never acknowledged Xavier
is my brother in the future that's also
why in the future I should be like a
bajillion years old and that's why
Marie movies they mellow and I've been
touch-and-go those are like the
cannibalism of continuity so they have
to try and stop that teria with the
glasses from making these giant robots
Italian is I President Nixon if we want
this program to work we have to convince
the people that's a dark scary fearful
world out there well you've come to the
right president for that but may need a
guess to the giant robots and switches
around their wiring fellow robots are
shooting all these humans well magneto
raises a stadium of everybody with him
II carry still inside I'm flying I knew
one day what finally happened but
mystique knocks out magneto decides not
to kill that Tyria with glasses and the
future has changed so all the shitty
moments in the other x-men movies never
happen and then in a very bizarre move
the writers of the movie come out dear
audience we're sorry for all the stupid
mistakes we made to butcher these movies
in the past please accept this cop-out
that makes absolutely no sense
whatsoever but you don't care because
for once you'll actually see a goddamn
x-men movie none of them will be knocked
out captured or dead they will actually
just be the freakin x-men oh my god the
expert are here they're all here they're
actually gonna be faithful to the comics
but maybe roll can go and your flying
powers and super-strength but maybe they
can bring Nightcrawler back though oh my
dad is like the comics are finally
coming to the screen so movie tell me
what are you gonna do the next one
they're going to fight apocalypse who is
a 16 year old boy
dammit the end do x-men Days of Future
past is a really really good movie and
so much better than that awful x-men 3
call me dim their wallets kill people
often the other films move giant
monuments around and not stick to the
comic book story with this one is
totally different
this one they tell people OFF from the
other films they move giant monument
around and they totally don't stick to
the comic book story my friends they are
finally starting to learn this is
jittery buncee shy you can't change I
come on if a guy away happens to my
judge
come on I'll use it to make the x-men or
appropriate age with the very least
appropriate rest days